Selam aleykum on the line with a cathode
this is brother mnemonic on this week's
episode we're going to be talking about
a question a sister asked in regards to
the hijab stay tuned bismillah hamdullah
Salaam alaikum peace be with you you're
watching the disha I'm Eddie your host
and we have nomen Ali Khan who's coming
up got the question here somebody wrote
in and they expressed their happiness
that they've embraced Islam that
submission that complete adherence
peacefully lovingly submitting yourself
to the one who created you not to a man
or a woman but the creator of man and
woman not to an animal to a idol or a
statue or an icon to the one creator who
created the Sun in a movement everything
in his universe he's the crate tour
where his creatures where his creation
we worship the one who created creation
and that's what this sister who wrote in
she accepted Islam she was like many of
the people who are out there today all
about the gossip magazines music movies
boys girls and all the other fun stuff
people perceive as fun and a lot of it's
just wasting time you just wasting time
because his life is a test and if we
don't pass then we don't get the
ultimate reward paradise so we got to
work in this life to please our critter
before we meet our Creator and that's
what Islam is all about Islam that
peaceful submission to the will of the
one create tour and this is how you
achieve peace when you submit to the
owner of peace and that's what she did
but she's a little bit confused because
there's some Muslims they're not acting
in accordance with Islam so we're gonna
be talking about that in her question so
you can't go nowhere we're gonna be
reading it out and you'll get to benefit
from her question and will given the
answer with no mentality can't hear
daddy show don't go nowhere
this is the thing is the thing this is
the thing
[Music]
Salam alaikum
like what's today I wanna please be with
you
no man Ali Khan my brother Eddie how are
you doing al hamdulillah praises to the
crater that happens on earth that you're
back with us again here in Chicago I'm
very elated I'm very excited that you're
here with us I'm really happy to be back
it's been a long time thank you very
much finding the time to be with us I
introduced the show mm-hmm and I told
our viewing audience that we're going to
cover a topic we're gonna cover that
this week's topic based on a question
that was sent in okay so I hate to rush
things but you know time is all we have
mm-hmm so the questioner is asking let's
get straight to the questions so we can
open up this topic the the sister Janet
or Jeanette I'm sorry she's asking
brother no man that I came to Islam a
few years ago after I had almost given
up on life my life before Islam revolved
around fashion gossip magazines music
movies boys and all the other things
that girls do at home did in law which
means all praises to the Creator Allah
guided me to Islam my question is
regarding the hijab which I have grown
to love I'm really starting to see the
wisdom behind it as I feel it has
uplifted me and has forced men to
respect me respect me I'm confused she's
saying she's saying brother Sheikh that
I'm confused and my question is about
many of my Muslim sisters who are born
into Islam and who take this for granted
by either arguing against the job saying
it's outdated or sisters who who wear
the the tightest of clothes and then put
on the hijab
isn't this countering the effect of what
is intended by the hijab she's asking
okay we're almost done this is what I
left behind so back in John Hadi
obviously so I'm confused when I see
Muslim sisters dressing in this
provocative way please do a show about
this Eddie as I feel many will benefit
from this including myself that's why
from the bunch we picked this one
because obviously I think it's a
relevant discussion it is definitely
yeah you see the things I see too don't
you
absolutely not
so please what are your comments on this
um I think this is a layered problem we
can't give a straight answer for this
kind of thing because at the end of the
day the sister is confused about what
she sees in other people's behavior that
she expects more from so let's start at
the top when it comes to the ruling of
her job and for that matter what it when
it comes to passing a verdict on
anything in Islam is it mandatory do you
have to do it or is it absolutely
impermissible you can't do it at all etc
it's very easy for average Muslims to
just quickly pass a verdict you can and
you can't right and you just go halal
and Haram there are very few things in
Islam that are absolutely no
disagreement there's no scholarly debate
about them and there's I mean pretty
much on the essentials of it there's
unanimity when it comes to things like
alcohol and interest and innocent you
know killing an innocent person and
these kinds of basic essential wrongs
then there's no this difference of
opinion among scholars hijab happens to
be one of those things overwhelmingly
there is actually no disagreement among
our scholars about what a job means what
are its mere minimum requirements there
may be some technical discussion about
you know what's the bare minimum that
constitutes a hijab and there may be
some kind of scholarly debate about that
but a job itself as an injunction
because it's in the Quran and it's very
direct and explicit and the Prophet I
saw to--some himself explained it in
very explicit terms there's not really
any kind of debate about whether or not
it's an essential part of Islam and
something required of women in Islam or
not that's not a dubious matter so it's
not clear it's not an unclear matter
it's it hasn't been until maybe the last
fifty years or something but I mean for
the vast majority of our history nobody
raised this issue there's not a new
meth-head no that's uh you know has a
different opinion on this it's just you
know in order to come up with a new
opinion on this you basically have to
say for most of Islam's history people
didn't know what they were talking about
from the Companions first generation
second generation all the way up until
modern times nobody knew what they were
talking about they were all a bunch of
idiots nobody knew either Lud we I'm not
obviously saying about them like this
but this is the opinion people have they
were backed by backwards they were
pre-modern they didn't understand our
context our situation has changed
therefore we have to look at
things in a new way etc etc the first
thing I want to share at least in terms
of my conviction and the conviction of
essentially you know mainstream Muslims
is that these these principles don't
change they are constants but at the
same time the second conversation that
has to be had in order to address the
sisters problem is that people are
complicated and you have to know
people's situations before you
understand why they behave in a certain
way and it's not just about a job you
know the sisters confused they're born
Muslims or Muslim as in this case and
they should know better and they're not
only not doing it but they're arguing
against it but as a matter of fact I've
met Muslims who argue in favor of
alcohol consumption who argue very
vehement ly about not praying because
they're already connected to God
spiritually etc etc I mean it's not the
only thing this mentality among Muslims
of you would be shocked how are you
Muslim if you're saying these kinds of
things how can these two things coexist
this is not limited to this one problem
so we have to understand it in the
context of a larger problem so what one
of the factors in that is in the Muslim
world and especially in the West we have
suffered from a lack of basic Muslim
education Islamic education and
essential grounding in the basic
teachings of this religion the core
teachings of this religion and at the
heart of that is whatever Allah says is
the best for us whatever instructions
he's given whether we understand the
wisdom behind them or not the logic
behind them or not because the sister
for example appreciated the benefit of
hijab that men are forced to respect her
and she sees the the blessings of it in
her practical life that's all great but
at the end of the day that's not the
reason for why she wears it the reason a
Muslim does anything Allah tells them to
do is because Allah told them to do it
that's the number one reason once Allah
tells you to do something and you trust
him it's not because you saw benefits it
is because you trust him you did the act
whatever it may be maybe maybe it's
prayer maybe it's leaving impermissible
sources of making money whatever it may
be once you came to obey Allah trusting
him then no doubt about it you'll start
seeing benefits the common mistake
Muslims make is when they argue in favor
of something Islamic they start talking
about its benefits
right those benefits are always going to
be there no doubt about it but that's
not the reason the reason is that it's
an instruction from Allah what
most Muslims haven't been indoctrinated
and haven't been you know our education
has become so weak our basic education
that we don't see it that way anymore
we don't see that what Allah has taught
us is absolutely the best for us and
whatever I think in my head I can come
up with is secondary to what Allah and
His Messenger I've already said that's
it's it's my best interest they're not
asking me to do something that it's not
beneficial to me it's only in my
favorite that's on the one side that's
about confusion in the lack of education
but there's another problem too there
are sisters I've met across the country
that used to wear hijab and took it off
they used to understand the least attend
classes they learned a lot they research
the issue if you ask them do you know
that her job is mandatory they'll tell
you yes so now you can argue my god I'm
right now I'm really confused because I
understand somebody who took it off or
doesn't wear it because they don't know
any better here's a sister that knows it
studied the issue and then took it off
what's going on there and it's too easy
to say these people are hypocrites or
they're they're not true believers or
they're it's it's not fair to them we
have to understand what's going on you
know we don't a lot of times appreciate
how difficult it can be you know I can't
appreciate as a man and you can't as a
man but a sisters perspective just like
they have a hard time understanding our
perspective right I have three daughters
a wife mom three sisters they don't
understand me like you know my father
can or another man can and I don't
understand them like they can understand
each other for a woman to go into
college her corporate workplace I
thought to work at the hospital whatever
else and for her to spend hours and
hours working around men and they look
at her funny and they say things and
they pass comments and it hurts her
feelings and she's constantly putting up
with that it can really take a toll on a
person and it's not easy for a girl to
take her hijab off it's a very difficult
decision there's something very personal
that happened in in their life that made
them do that or is keeping them from
putting it on it's more than just
they're not convinced it's the best or
that it's outdated these are just things
to say but what's going on behind the
scenes is there's fear there's real
concern there are people making all
kinds of weird arguments like if you put
it on you'll become
of attention I thought the point of her
job was to get a not get attention but
once you put it on you become the full
center of attention so there's there's a
lot of psychological stuff going on that
has to be solved at a person-to-person
basis it can't be resolved in one speech
and the behavior of others we can't pass
judgment on that easily because we don't
know what's going on behind the scenes
just like somebody who's drinking of
course it's Haram but what led the guy
to drink what kind of trauma did he go
through we have to kind of deal with
people in the human sort of way and
that's what our messenger did so Allah
already said I'm essentially far there's
a third point but perhaps I've got to
take a break yeah I'll come back with
more here answering your question on the
Deen show love like bum love egg bomb
subhanAllah open hamdulillah I'm glad I
let her in na na na egg bum love egg bum
Allah alhamdulillah la illaha illallah
w'allahu akbar i love egg bomb
subhanAllah when hamdulillah I'm gonna
let her in na na na egg bomb
I love egg bomb had Allah open
hamdulillah I'm glad I let her in na na
na egg bomb I love egg bomb
subhanAllah when hamdulillah I'm gonna
allow her in na na na egg bomb I love
[Music]
[Music]
back here with no man Ali Khan on the
Dean show and we are talking about the
issue of hijab and you're gonna go in to
point number three yeah just to recap
very quickly the first point is that the
ruling hasn't changed and it's not
something that's opened a really
discussion in the highest scholarly
circles in our tradition seem like
alcohol prayer all these things are the
basics the essential fundamentals the
second point I made was even though
that's constant that doesn't give me
license to judge somebody and say you're
doing you know how could you do this
you're a Muslim because I don't know
what's going on in their life what what
they're going through in their head and
you know a lot of times what we see on
the outside is behavior but maybe
there's something really going on inside
the heart that has to be addressed
that's the root problem you know and the
same goes for the third point a third
point I wanted to make is our teachings
in Islam they are you could put them
under big chapters big headings you can
organize our religion that way like you
know famous books of Islamic studies
like for example they have entire
chapters under with which multiple areas
are studied so you can have a large
chapter called worship and ended Hajj
and pilgrimage and prayer and fasting
etc I've studied under that one large
chapter well the hijab if you were to
put it under a chapter you would
probably put it under the chapter of
modesty of shame of guarding yourself
and this is one lesson of many lessons
inside this chapter a lot of times what
people do is they say this is all the
song has to say about modesty once I put
this thing on my head now all of a
sudden I have modesty of course not no
I'm a modest person anyway the question
arises then you know the word modesty or
shame I can have my own definition of it
and you can have your own I mean every
two other two three other people have
their own definition of decency of shame
of appropriateness different parents
allow their kids to watch different
things don't they some kids some parents
they'll have no problem their kids are
watching MTV or they're going out to a
movie or what
others will censor every little thing
and say there's no TV in our house
people have different standards the
question is when you accept Islam by
definition you've submitted your
standards to Allah standards so when it
comes to modesty also you've submitted
I don't maybe I have some idea what
shame is but Allah knows better than I
do and this is part of his standards of
modesty what I'm trying to say then is
there's a hijab on what a person's face
there's a hijab on a person's head
there's a jet Bob there's a large larger
garment a looser garment that they're
wearing or loose clothing in general but
there's also modesty of one's
personality right in how we how we walk
how we talk our body language how we
carry ourselves how we behave with
people that aren't from our family with
the opposite gender these are all things
that are in the in essence extended
lessons of hijab you're missing the
point
if you don't know what chapter this
belongs to so you'll have sisters that
are even wearing hijab but don't
understand the larger concept of modesty
and even brothers for that matter they
don't understand a lot of larger concept
of modesty and they're violating other
lessons within that chapter so what if
they observed her job the other tenants
are still there they have to be observed
but you know respected also so it is in
fact an essential component of modesty
whether you make common sense of it or
not is irrelevant
just like prayer is a lot teaching us
how to be spiritual I can come up with
my own Spiritual Exercises and same what
we know I think my technique works a lot
better I start with such that I start
with prostration and then work my way
back up to the standing in prayer I've
come up with a different sequence it
doesn't work because what Allah has
taught is what defines our spirituality
this is how you're supposed to exercise
your spirituality you know that's the
ideal the same thing goes with hijab the
same thing goes with our dietary
restrictions you know so it is part of
that larger thing and there's one more
thing that should be said about this
high job issue a lot of times sisters
get the feeling that this is a
restriction on women and how come men
don't have the same thing and you know
it becomes like a equal rights type
thing or women's lib type issue and
that's how it's framed
that's not fair to the Dean also first
of all if we believe this is the
religion of truth then we believe that
Allah created man and
and he knows man better than man knows
himself and he knows woman better than
woman knows herself and he knows exactly
what man needs that he knows exactly
what woman needs let me give you a small
example so parents they see their kids
having an argument
they take both kids and they give them a
solution you do this and you do that one
of them says oh it's not fair you always
side with that one the matter of fact is
maybe the parent does fear one over the
other and you know prefer one over the
other because that's a human being in
the end it's a parent or maybe the
parent knows better in the case of Allah
solving our disputes there's a woman
saying Allah has more restrictions on
women that he has on men
this debate becomes a debate between man
and woman and who's gonna resolve that
debate Elias
when we accept Quran as guidance that
we've said Allah is going to be more
fair to me than anybody else can be and
as an extension I want to share with you
a beautiful ayah surah nisa this is the
surah of women Allah says well our
tamino mappable allahabad oakum on a
favela we bout to come on about i'll
translate in english don't give don't
wish for what Allah Himself gave
preference in terms of some over the
other Allah give someone some blessings
some powers some rights some
restrictions and he gave you different
rights different different
responsibilities different restrictions
don't vie for the other and say how come
I can't have what he has and he
shouldn't say how come I have what she
has Allah says literally jolliness EBU
me Marcus Abu same ayah he says for men
they will only have what they get to
earn and good deeds that's in the end
what they've earned for themselves well
in decide you know single men worked as
a plan for women all they get is what
they've earned in terms of good deeds
well cool Anwar you know what Solomon
family and ask Allah for his favor don't
vie for one another's things it is not a
competition between men and women this
is a competition and who does more good
deeds Allah changes our mentality about
the subject you know so this is really a
thinking an intellectual transformation
that a person has to go through and
until they go through that they're not
gonna see the point in any of Allah's
instructions whichever they don't want
to follow they can easily say it's
outdated it's not for our times it's not
fair they can come up with a list of
complaints and that's not something
restricted to non-muslims it'll happen
to Muslims too just like that sister it
went through a transformation and came
to Islam we're at a time now where a lot
of Muslims have to go through a trance
and also come back to Islam I like what
you said earlier okay you made a clear
lucid definition you said okay now I'm
sorry you said that the prayer just like
the prayer alcohol there fix things and
since the creator revealed to the last
and final mention depart my home and
peace be upon him and then how his
companions and then the scholars after
that and then you can safely say the
format's halves this thing is clear the
issue is not really debatable right now
people had then you went on to to talk
about the things that us not judging the
the person but can we say that now for
the sister who life
she made a life-changing move she went
from living a life of following her
desires to Islam submitting to the
Creator uh-huh now that she doesn't look
at she shouldn't get discouraged looking
at what Muslims are doing Tom Islam is
pristine it's clear so don't get shaken
up by what they're doing that's one
point the other point is please define
for our sister who don't know they don't
know they think okay I can wear the
tight jeans and all the junk is coming
out and all this I'm sorry you know it
just the the the the the tawdry dress
and they just throw on a piece of cloth
over their head you know and say you
know this is I'm fulfilling the my
responsive but they don't know so the
two things address please and we're
really almost out of time so okay hit
both of them her not to get discouraged
and the other part of what is hijab what
constitutes hijab is it is it just the
the cloth over the head two things yeah
number one she should not only should
she not be discouraged she should
understand what she's come into she's
come into a religion that calls people
to the light in other words her job is
not to see miss behavior of others and
be discouraged by it but be encouraged
that she has work to do she's part of it
oh ma now that is an Ouma of loving
reminder to others right so when she
sees others falling into a behavior she
doesn't say this is wrong but she says
let me remind them of who lives let me
remind them for what Allah does for them
let me bring them let me soften their
hearts a little bit and then you know
when the diseases addressed the symptoms
will change not wearing a hijab is not
the disease it's a symptom the diseases
inside and we can't be discouraged by
these symptoms we have to attack the
disease what that person might just need
is a good friend with some soft
encouragement with patients was over
time and they'll transform completely
right so that's that's one
major point what was your second point
again then second point we're gonna take
a break and then we're gonna address the
second point okay we come back here in
the Dean show don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
[Music]
it's a way of life or to us man the
messenger best of me show us the way to
others Chris this is the D D now this
man this is the D D nervous back on the
Dean show an omen Ali Khan and we were
answering a sister's question who we
congratulate her she came from living a
life of chasing her desires
she recognized with the crater that
heavens and earth is that Islam is the
way and she's living this way and she's
confused because some Muslims she's
thinking they should be living this to
was there's a contradiction here so
we're answering the contradiction and we
left off with defining hijab because
some sisters they might wear tight
clothes that's correct think just put
the veil on and this is a job very good
I think this is a good opportunity to
share some very important basics for all
new Muslims Muslims that are trying to
learn their religion and then address
the topic of a job directly you know
when it comes to legal issues in Islam
how do you define legal things
restrictions it's very important that we
get our answers from scholarly sources
that we don't get our answer from to be
very blunt people like me I'll tell you
what that means I'm a Quran teacher and
I'm an Arabic teacher those are the two
things I study in my research Islamic
law Sharia fit is an area of expertise
and no matter how much I think I may
have studied and I've taught when it
comes to a matter of hick and Sharia I
go to an expert in that area and say can
you define it for me even though I can
do the research myself I would rather
somebody who's poured their life
studying this stuff and asked them hard
questions and get the answer so what I'm
gonna share with you is a basic
definition this is what the scholars are
obviously saying I'm just gonna tell
them right there's but my word means
nothing
even if I'm quoting the scholars in the
end my word on this issue means nothing
some people would rather
listen to you because you speak the
vernacular language of the you yeah and
they look up to say hey I can relate to
him better so they might take it from
you rather than taking it from someone
that's true but now more and more we
have contemporary well-spoken articulate
young you know American scholars that
are up and coming and I think they
should be put on the spot on these kinds
of issues too but nonetheless all
defined some very basic essentials you
know our job all the differences you
know additional opinions aside the
minimum is the hair to be covered and of
a loose cloth that covers the front of
know the chest of the woman in a loose
way the gel bob is the second item of
clothing and by the way the hijab the
Quranic term for that is clima Seema
okay Markham silver hammer and the word
common literally means to cover
something from it also comes the word
humble is also the word for alcohol why
because it covers your intellect you
can't think straight which is a
beautiful word because then people ask
us beer okay because I'm not drinking
wine some other means white anything
that overshadows your intellect in the
least bit is how not automatically so it
takes care of that issue but regardless
Ahmad means something that covers and
that's for the top garment then it comes
for the the garment of the rest of the
body it's supposed to be an outer
garment gel Bob something that covers
over the way that's been interpreted
essentially is something that's some
basic conditions one it's not
form-fitting its loose and it goes down
in some debate whether it goes down to
half the shin or all the way down to the
ankle but regardless it's pretty long
it's a long over garment that is not
form-fitting then there's also debate
about whether is it one piece or two
pieces is it one long piece and one
shorter piece can it be it does it have
to be one long piece and these are
academic discussions but the main point
is it has to be loose and not
form-fitting at all say it again loose
loose not form-fitting and an outer
garment form-fitting shape at a body
right so it's not be it can't be tight
clothing it can't be the shape of these
precious things that should be maybe for
your for your husband not every you know
tomjohn can see that yeah and you know
that makes absolutely complete sense
because the Prophet Ayatollah said I
mean a very famous hadith actually
cursed a category of women kasi Atari at
he called them dressed but naked he
called him dressed but naked and what
that meant was form-fitting see-through
kinds of clothes etc these are the women
see-through
see through no no no see through right
tie jeans I mean we some people like if
you want to say jeans you know if you
want to wear this put a put an overcoat
on top or something and put something
longer on top or whatever nothing
nothing nothing showing the shape yeah
and that's you know that's a the the
basic definition to a modest muslima to
a modest most EMA is something that she
doesn't even have to do research for she
even has to ask herself if I was
standing in front of my father in front
of my brother would I be the least bit
embarrassed would I be the least bit
uncomfortable now there for some people
they've lived around them in the life of
shamelessness for so long that their
sense of shame has died so they say yeah
I have no problem saying like this but
for people that you know have a sense of
modesty they know they know they're
about to go to a party they dressed a
certain way and if their mother saw them
their father saw them their older
brother saw them their uncle saw them
they'd be embarrassed they'd be taken
back well you know what if your personal
conscience is sounding off the alarm
you're probably on the wrong track I
mean there's a fatwa being passed as the
legal really being passed by your own
conscience
so these legal discussions aside it's
just a matter of what you just dressing
respectfully and not exposing yourself
in a way that's not becoming a you know
a decent woman and a believer and
attitude the good the the good persona
that comes with it because some people
argue about hey she's wearing the right
hijab but she don't have the right
attitude you know I've seen this girl
who is wearing hijab as she's doing
worse than the one who's naturally you
bring up a really good point I'm almost
out of time yeah I need you just let me
let me make this point a concise on the
other end of the aisle or people that
aren't observing these things any aspect
of religion let's take a job in this
case to the discussion and the point of
people that are wearing hijab would have
a bad attitude or they're messed up in
some other way in their backbite or
they're dating or whatever else they're
doing that's not stuff even though they
have the hijab on and they got the outer
garment on and everything right just
like people misbehaving are not a source
of discouragement for me that is trying
to behave just like that people that are
misbehaving can't quote bad examples and
say therefore I don't have to answer to
God you're not responsible because you
saw a good example or a bad example the
examples already been revealed
the sample has already been revealed the
role models have already come and gone
last point I'm trying to make we don't
look for role models that are around us
the very first sort of the Quran tells
us to look for role models that have
already left and then Lina and Anne
Tolley in the path of those who you
already showered past tense not those
who shower right now because I don't
know if they're gonna be on the right
path tomorrow we look for righteous
guidance in those in the past the entire
Quran is full of stories of those who
already passed that's that's what we're
supposed to look for four pillars of
guidance not anybody else on the anchor
our hopes and then we're constantly
disappointed and then we lose end up
losing our faith a couple more points
we're almost out of time sure tell us
now tell us now please you said you
mentioned some sisters who know about
hijab they know the verdict they know
this is something that is compulsory on
every Muslim woman and they take it off
let's say but now you see them take it
off should we encourage the sisters who
are wearing it but they see educated
let's say a sister and she just took it
off can this be a test from Allah
because this life is a test and let's
save everyone and their mother took it
off you be the one that keeps it on
because it's a test and can allah be
testing you through those people that's
created them just for that specific
person to test you and now you because
50 people took it off you take it off -
you failed on test and the other thing
that happens is a girl takes it off
whatever she's going through and the
other girl's inner circle that are still
laying hijab they start looking at her
funny and she goes all they look at me
fine I don't want to you want to hang
out with them so she finds different
company now she doesn't even have
someone to remind her and those it's the
fault of those other girls that do wear
hijab that became judgemental all of a
sudden they should have been supportive
at that time that's what community is a
cult judges people that become different
a community takes in people that are
fallen and says let me get you back up
you know we have to be communities we
can't turn into cults we can't turn into
cliques that people avoid us because
they don't want to be judged that by
definition means we've turned into a
cult so if you have a sister in your
group that has become like that you have
to reach out and befriend her and not
discuss hijab just be a friend all she
needs is a friend right now
she doesn't need a lecture about whether
she should why she should buy a job when
she already knows that what she needs
right now is just some comfort and
somebody to be able to relate to and
eventually if when her heart softened
and that's up to allah may allah azza
which will bring her back to committing
herself to all aspects of the deen
including the hijab thank you so much
for fun
trying to be with us while Khalil here
come and show us afford to have you back
again rate to be bestial how time flies
yes Thank You suppli - vehicle and thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Dene show we like to congratulate
our sister who took that choice that she
has of either worshiping the creation or
worshiping the crater sister Jeanette
who accepted his way of life of all the
messengers of God the worship of the one
create tour and she submitted in Islam
Samantha's Islam simply meaning to
acquire peace by submitting to the owner
peace to create or the one God the same
God that Jesus Moses Abraham and the
last and final messenger the problem
Hamid peace be upon him and all of them
they all submitted to the one God and
you've done that never get discouraged
always rely on the one who created you
the one who gives you the air that you
breathe the eyes that you see with a
notice life is a test and if you pass
the test by obeying your Creator loving
your Creator doing what your Creator
wants you to do paradise that's the
ultimate prize so never get discouraged
and everybody keep tuning in here to the
Deen show we'll see you next time until
then peace be unto you
this is the this is the
do you know is
[Music]